les gares deviennent de plus en plus
féminin c'est plus des mecs
les femmes nous ont volé la robe
depuis le 16e siècle je vais leur
reprendre progressivement et siècle
partiel tout ce qu'elles nous ont pris
[Musique]
vous avez vu son roc pour hommes que si
vous en pensez celui là chacun doit
garder son rôle et sur 7 pour moi non
plus non alors bien plus distinguer les
hommes avec qui on peut pas savoir
cette obstination un peu plus le savoir
je crois que je suis content tout les
ségrégations qu'elle soit la ségrégation
de la couleur qu'elle soit la
ségrégation du sexe je ne dis pas qu'il
faut s'habiller comme ça je dis on peut
s'habiller comme ça c'est ma révolution
c'est fantastique invite tellement marre
de tous ces petits hommes gris sa
machette pense que ça va devenir sens je
pense à passer la main facile maintenant
faite à l'amiable g prend la même
sensation c'est très excitant
[Musique]
paris est devenue contrat marque en
force une vieille dame respectable qui
ne demande qu'à être violée alors je
désire
[Musique]